madame monsieur bonsoir ce samedi
marquée par une actualité sportive
extrêmement riche
bien évidemment la finale du mondial
dans tous les esprits nous y reviendrons
dans un instant mais d'abord cette
affaire qui se déroule en marge du tour
de france et qui a suscité tout au long
de la journée une certaine émotion
un soigneur de l'équipe festina été
arrêté à la frontière franco-belge en sa
possession 400 flacons de produits
dopants en tout genre celui qui n'est
autre que le soigneur personnel de
richard virenque a été interpellé
mercredi et présenté au parquet l'idylle
derrière alexandre kara nathalie gallet
à l'entraînement en apparence rien ne
reflète le malaise est pourtant pour
l'équipe festina l'une des favorites le
tour commence bien mal depuis hier sur
le tour un seul mot est sur toutes les
lèvres dopage
un vent de tempête qui vient de la
frontière belge où l'un des soigneurs de
l'équipe a été arrêté en possession
d'une importante quantité de produits
interdits
ça me confirme surtout il faut être très
déterminé dans la lune autres et
pourvoyeur de ses produits dopants qui
amène ses produits dopants vers les
sportifs c'est mercredi midi que vit les
voûtes ma soeur de festina de
nationalité belge a été arrêté dans sa
voiture les douaniers ont découvert des
centaines de gélules d'anabolisants
ainsi que de le paix au un produit qui
favorise l'oxygénation du sang
le masseur de l'équipe festina était
présenté au parquet et mis en examen
probablement pour infraction à la
législation sur les stupéfiants
à la suite de cette interpellation les
enquêteurs ont effectué jeudi soir une
perquisition au siège français de
festina près de lyon sur place les
policiers auraient découvert d'autres
produits suspects à dublin le directeur
sportif de festina a déclaré avoir
appris cette affaire par la presse
pour lui il ne peut pas y avoir de
conséquence directe pour son équipe dans
la 106 1 on peut pas
je veux dire interpellé des gens qui ont
a priori rien à voir avec cette affaire
est bon je crois que le mieux c'est de
chacun puisse faire son travail et la
justice et nous mêmes sur ce tour de
france et la cour ce matin
pardon jean marie leblanc le directeur
du tour annoncé qu'il attendrait les
conclusions de la justice pour réagir
tout en excluant l'éventualité d'une
sanction collective
il n'est pas envisageable pour une
action frauduleuse peut être isolé qui
c'est de priver toute une équipe et
surtout des coureurs d'une participation
au tour de france
cette affaire est de toute façon un coup
dur pour l'équipe festina qui compte
dans ses rangs trois des favoris du tour
alex zülle le richard virenque et
laurent dufaux pour leur part les
dirigeants d'equipe pourrait être
entendu par les enquêteurs dès leur
retour en france mardi prochain